[Music]
Kendall it is so wonderful to be here
with you today thank you for joining me
thanks for having me I'm happy to be
here of course so you are a household
name everyone I think knows you you've
had a successful modeling career what
made you want to take the leap into
entrepreneurship um I think I always
felt a really strong passion for it
obviously I come from a family of a
bunch of entrepreneurs so I think it
felt really natural for me I felt like I
was in a place in um my modeling career
as it was I was it was like coming up on
maybe nine um now almost 10 years where
I was just really ready for something
new and kind of to take control of my
own business in a way and um so I was I
was really excited for it I always felt
really drawn to it I just wanted to be
really intentional with what I was going
to go for and and I honestly think it
was nice to take the time and to kind of
mature Within Myself and grow and get
older and realize what I wanted to do
and where I wanted to be and feel like I
was ready for that step so I I felt
really ready and it's almost
Indescribable I think I gave you some
words but it's kind of a moment where
you just wake up and you're like okay I
feel like I'm really ready for this
point in my life so that's so cool and I
going along with that I've always
thought like out of every single product
or thing that you could have chosen why
did you decide to start with tequila and
I love tequila was a fan well there you
go I feel like it was it was a lot of
that obviously I was a fan as a consumer
of of tequila um and so I really loved
it and when I kind of I mean it's to
make a long story short I guess it was
it was something that was always my mom
and my dad drank it all the time growing
up I always heard about it and then you
know as I got older and I would start
drinking it I kind of was like loving
playing around with as a consumer
tasting different Tequilas loving
different Tequilas kind of just loving
the space again as a consumer not
knowing too much about the ins and outs
of it and um found myself really excited
about it and really passionate about it
for I call it Destiny I'm just like I
don't know why but it ALS all of a
sudden kind of I fell in love with it I
fell in love with the space and really
um was kind of looking at all angles and
then um one day thought it would be
really fun to to have a tequila for me
and my friends it kind of started there
as the smaller idea and then one thing
led to the next and I had a whole team
behind me and I um found partners and
Founders that also really wanted to be a
part of the space and then we then grew
obviously we didn't know much about
making tequila so we had to find the
experts and through our team from there
and um that's kind of the really quick
version of how it came to be and how I
got excited about it but it was it was
basally me just being a fan of the space
and um really enjoying seeing products
that I had seen on the shelves and
enjoying them and thinking oh this would
be really really fun for me and my
friends to have something and then it
grew into this whole situation that we
have now awesome and you talk about this
great team that you built can you
describe that a little bit about the
people who you surround yourself with
who help your business and and how that
works yeah I mean I think that's
obviously one of the most important
things in any business is surrounding
yourself with people that know that that
they're the best at what they do and I
think we were really eager to find those
people and I feel we did our team is so
amazing and we're small But Mighty I'd
say still and we definitely started
really small But Mighty um but we really
we really went after some um some big
players I guess in the industry who've
been around for 40 plus years who really
know what they're doing and um I feel
very lucky and blessed that they were
like that they took the leap of faith
and the jump and they took the risk to
come be with us on our team and it's
just really worked out really well and I
lean on them for so much information and
so much knowledge and I've learned so
much from them so I just feel really
grateful to have had them on our team
and yeah it's been really cool that's
awesome and there's so many of these
celebrity tequila brands out there you
know R Ora George Clooney The Rock a lot
of different people were you nervous um
about standing out in a crowded industry
and how do you set yourself apart I
consider that like I consider that a
healthy challenge like I think we were
really ready we obviously know that
there's a lot of amazing brands on on
the market an amazing tequila on the
market so for us it just made us want to
be better and this was not something
that um someone came to me with an idea
or a brand that was already in
development and wanted me to join this
was completely my idea from the jump and
a and a startup complete groundup
process and so I feel like for that
reason alone I really wanted I would
never have done this had I not put not
only 100% of my energy and my love into
it but also really made it an amazing
product like I really wanted premium
liquid I wanted amazing packaging I
wanted all the things to line up really
beautifully so I think that for me it
was it was just a big part of like
obviously standing out is a is a huge
thing for it as well because there are a
lot of other brands but I think that I
don't know I just I wanted it to feel
100% And I think that it that only drove
me to feel like we had to be at the best
of the top of our game basically knowing
that there was other great products out
there absolutely and one of the things
that I always read about 818 and that I
think is really cool is that it's a
family-owned and operated distillery in
Mexico tell me about production how
involved are you uh talk to me about the
the process I am involved every step of
the way my hand is pretty much in every
aspect of the business obviously I don't
physically make the tequila but I I'm
involved in everything yeah we're we're
partnered with an amazing Distillery
group O salave they are run by the Perez
Family they're amazing I'm obsessed with
them just like the sweetest kindest
people and we got really lucky I think
that what was really cool about grouos
salave was um coming into their
Distillery and realizing they had so
many things that aligned with us at 818
and the biggest thing was their
sustainability efforts and um my
involvement is all around like I I'm I'm
involved in everything we have weekly
Zoom calls and we're on the phone with
every single person on our team pretty
much all the executives and we're
talking creative and all any type of
business conversation and we're pretty
much all around the board and I'm always
getting up to Ates on what's going on
down at The Distillery and all the
things so and obviously I'm visiting
pretty frequently as well so I'm sure I
feel really grateful because I like I
said about having a great team like the
Perez family is just amazing and being
partnered with this Distillery is
probably like I feel so blessed and I
feel so like honored that we're part of
their system and they're just amazing so
that's great awesome yeah now you
mentioned at the beginning of this
interview you come from a family of
entrepreneurs that's clear your sisters
all have their own businesses how do you
stand out and what is the the Kendall
brand that you're trying to go for I
mean I think that we all have our own
Vibe our own personalities miss my
sisters and I my family and I and I
don't know I feel that I've probably
said this before a million times um in
other just interviews but like I I feel
like since I was a kid I kind of always
was a little bit like and and not to say
that either is good or bad it was just I
was always a little different I was
always kind of sportier and maybe not as
girly or you know stuff like that so I I
just always felt like I had a little bit
of a different path or something and
then um yeah I I don't I don't think
that any of it means one thing or the
other I just think that my path led me
here and I think that it feels really
fitting for me and I really enjoy it but
um it's interesting because I can ask
for advice all day long from the people
that have from my sisters who've done
you know have made their own businesses
and stuff like that but I feel like
there's still some differences just
obviously within the industries so did
you ever feel I think I wanted to
challenge myself yeah that's what I was
going to ask like did you feel a
pressure at all to like all right I got
to be an entrepreneur I got to be a
Founder cuz all them no I don't think I
felt pressure I think I was really
excited about it um I think like we said
earlier like my my mom my grandma my
sisters they they all kind of were those
entrepreneur had that great spirit and
so I um I really just followed their
lead I think it was like kind of natural
in a sense um and it felt just right I
don't know it felt really good yeah no
that's awesome describe how you spend
your time
these days like is it mostly 818 is it
filming Kardashians is it modeling talk
walk me through that it's a bit of
everything it's like a good it's a good
mixture of all um I think my main focus
is my business is 818 um but I I still
have so much fun modeling and doing all
those amazing things so I think that I
find time for everything sometimes it
gets a little overwhelming AKA maybe
this next these next couple weeks but I
I really don't take it for granted and I
think that I I love love working and I
love staying busy and so I really enjoy
it and I and I am a lucky Lucky Gal and
I get to do all these fun things that
were dreams of mine as since a young kid
so I'm really happy that's amazing and
speaking of of things you do um everyone
knows you love horses and that's a hobby
of yours is there any little known thing
that people don't know about you that
you do in your spare time I'm like a big
Chiller I don't really do much chilling
is great I chill I love like I love
sporty things like I love anything thing
cuz I feel like I just kind of grew up a
sporty gal I love getting outside and I
don't know I was I'm trying to think of
anything sporty I like just I like we we
ride around and we do like wake surfing
like in at this Lake where we go it's
just like all this fun stuff so I just
love anything adventurous and outdoorsy
but like that's fun I'm pretty boring
like I swear I'm pretty boring well that
leads into my next question it's like I
feel like you know you've been sharing
everything your whole life is there
anything that's too personal that you're
say like I won't share this at all yeah
I mean I have a lot of that I'm like
very much I like like to keep private
stuff private personal stuff private
like I just I don't know I've always
kind of been that way even since I was a
kid like before anything like I just
always was kind of like it's my business
and nobody else's so it's just always
kind of been my motto speaking of that I
think people also again feel like they
know you because they see this one side
of you that's out there um is there a
part of that people don't see that you
wish that they saw yeah I mean I think
that that's kind of the the tricky part
about wanting to keep a private life is
I think it gives more room for people to
create a narrative for you and think
that they they can kind of put you in
this place or in this box and be like
okay she's this girl because maybe
they've seen one or two things that they
think has convinced them of an entire
lifestyle of mine um so that can get
frustrating I think at times when you're
like it's not not accurate whatsoever
but it's okay um so I think that that's
where I I get a little conflicted in
like okay I want to be as private as I
possibly can for my own sanity and
mental well-being um and it just makes
me happy I think to keep things sacred
and safe um so I just and then I'm like
okay well then that also leaves a little
bit more room for people to create their
own narratives but I think I've accepted
that and I and I know that the people
around me and the people that love me
and um the people that I want to know
those things about me my quirky side my
silly side my freak freaky weird sides
like all those things I think that I all
my special people around me now and I'm
happy with that that's that's that's all
you can ask for honestly and you know
famous families they come and go but
none has really had the viral staying
power that your family has why do you
think that is I don't know I guess I
like I think that it's obviously a
special kind
of maybe once in a once in a few decades
once in a century thing but it's it's
obviously there's something I mean I
it's like hard for me to answer that
question but we're wild and we're funny
and we're crazy but at the same time I
think behind it all like the main the
main energy behind it all is love and we
just like have so much love for each
other we stand by each other and I think
that maybe that's it I I I can't really
fully answer the question no that's a
good I guess that's what I try and
equate it to I guess so for a lot of the
under 30 Founders that I talk with a big
problem is impostor syndrome they don't
feel like you know I'm empowered to be a
Founder I'm too young I'm too X but you
it's times 100 since you're in the
public eye did you ever feel this way
and how did you get around that yeah I
think I I think I feel it a lot um I
think there's a lot of pressure being
one in the spotlight but then also um
obviously running a a business um a
business of your own so I think that
I've felt that at times for sure I think
I always try and like I'm as corny as it
sounds I'm a big affirmations person so
I'm always trying to talk up to myself
and talk kindly to myself and remind
myself that I'm worthy of all the things
and that um everything is placed in my
life for a reason and all the things so
I feel like and I and I do feel prepared
I do feel really like kind of what I was
mentioning in the beginning I feel like
a lot of where I was in my life when I
made this decision was um at a place
where I felt like I was ready um and I
also felt like I was just meant to be
here at that time so sorry to get a
little spiritual but I just feel like
that those gen those feelings genuinely
help me get through those moments of
impostor syndrome and I think um yeah
that's that's helpful hopefully that's
great question I think that if you weren
already famous if you weren't already
celebrity do you think you would have
still gone and been an entrepreneur yeah
I feel like I I have kind of that like
work fighter mentality um and I think
that I have a lot of drive in that sense
so I do think that probably something
would have come along um I think about
that all the time because I'm like where
would I have been had I not been doing
this and and there's never really
obviously super clear answers because
it's the unknown but um I do feel like
I'd probably have some sort of I don't
know I'd be like an interior design or
something I like love that kind of stuff
so I feel like just naturally I maybe
would have ended up somewhere like that
but knows cool yeah you never know do
you have one business rule that you
operate by always no matter what um I
think a lot of it is has to do with like
trust your gut and I think that also
surrounding yourself which we've also
kind of T talked about a little bit here
but surrounding yourself with people who
you really trust and who you feel um
really like specialize in a certain
place that you might need that like
uplifting help and I think that you know
just the pros and like people that are
really smart and want to feed you great
advice and have your back genuinely I
think that that's all super super
important so yeah your environment and
all the things but also your gut that's
probably the biggest thing for me is
following my gut that's a great piece of
advice um and speaking of business so
for you your family is really you know
synonymous with with business how do you
separate you know your your family time
versus the the financial how do you
navigate that Dynamic it's so funny you
ask because obviously my mom is my mom
but she's also my manager so we have
moments like when we're talking on the
phone and we're talking about business
and we're like maybe having a heated
conversation about something and then
all of a sudden she's like okay I love
you how are you feeling today and I'm
like oh my God like yeah you're my mom
too like and then we'll go talk about
something else like a bad day or
whatever very mom stuff mom daughter
related things so so there is that that
sometimes there can be confusing moments
where I'll come over to my mom's house
on a Sunday and she just wants to chill
and I just want to chill and then we end
up getting in these debates about work
stuff or whatever we end up talking
about so and I'm like but it's Sunday we
should just be mom and daughter right
now so we have our moments but at the
end of the day I think we're really good
at compartmentalizing I think all of us
are we're all pretty pretty Pro not to
toot our horns but we're pretty Pro and
I think we get we get the separation
between like work fam time and business
time and all those things that makes
sense um and speaking of of you and work
in Brands so 818 is definitely your big
business but the other business I think
is is you as Kendall how do you decide
which brands and posts to to be
sponsored or who do you decide who to
work with um that's a that's also very
intentional for me like I'm I find
myself to be a very intentional person
so anytime I'm like working with a brand
or um creating a brand or just doing
something that is genuinely mean
obviously everything has to feel super
authentic to me but again super
intentional like I don't want to I don't
want to do anything that doesn't align
with my vibes or my morals or my
feelings and things that really make me
feel good and make me feel like getting
excited to wake up in the morning and I
and I had to work to get to that place
it wasn't always it wasn't always that
easy I can't just say yes and no to
everything I can't say no to a lot of
things especially 10 years ago when I
was starting you know it was a lot of
yeses and a lot of um not only feeling
great F to be in that position but just
feeling like you know I wanted to build
up my portfolio and my career and all
the things but now I think I have the
blessing of being able to say okay does
that align with me and I wake up a
really happy person because of that and
so that's been something that I you know
kind of had to find I don't think that
came supernaturally there was a rough
patch where I was like I'm saying yes to
a lot do I need to say yes to all this
and so finding that happy middle and um
finding the blessing in that is also
really important for me that's great and
talk to me about what's coming up for
you next in 2024 what projects excite
you right now I mean I have I have stuff
on the rise for sure and I'm very
excited about a lot of things but I'm
also I love I love to live in the
present and I think that I'm really just
trying to hone in on obviously although
818 is two and a half years old I I'm
trying to also still live she's she's
pretty young she's a baby so I'm still
trying to live here and just enjoy it
and also put a lot of my energy and my
focus into it because I want to build it
up to be amazing and really great so um
a lot of my energy is there and I think
I'm just kind of focusing on that but I
do have things that always are flowing
through my head I cannot wait to hear
about them at some point in the future
um now going back to to you as a Founder
an 818 can you describe for me the
biggest challenges you faced while being
a first- Time founder um I think
obviously there's a there's a learning
curve and there's a lot of things that
you pick up on and obviously I think one
of the biggest things for me was um
going from being you know you wake up as
a model you wake up every morning and
you're you're almost playing a character
you're doing what you're told you're
you're following instruction you're on
set you're following what the
photographer wants with the creative
director once you're wearing what the
stylist tells you all those things which
is again super blessed to be in the
position that I was in I've worked with
some of the best people of all time and
fashion so I'm really really happy to
have learned everything and absorbed
everything that I have but um I think
what was really cool and a bit of a
learning curve and it kind of goes into
that like imposter syndrome thing where
I was like oh wait I'm the boss like
when I when I started 18 it was a little
bit like oh my God like I can I can call
the shots I can say this I can make the
bottle look like whatever I want the
bottle to look like and I could have the
the liquid taste the way that we all
love the liquid to taste so it just felt
cool to be kind of in the in the
captain's seat for a second I mean not
for a second I'm still there but it felt
nice to be in the captain seat and um I
think that was a big shift for me there
was obviously a learning curve and then
also recognizing that being the leader
and being the like the boss I guess was
also setting a tone for the rest of the
team and so you know having that
positive energy walking into a room and
having that good vibe is always going to
like end up reflecting on the entire
team and what comes out of the product
and all the things yeah not be a Founder
no but it was but it's been really
really cool and such an experience and
there's challenges and um obviously like
being a a female founder in a
predominantly male-dominated space like
all those things have obviously affected
certain things and but we take those as
like positive challenges and we just
want to become it it strives we strive
to be the best version of ourselves at
818 and like right it just honestly sets
the bar higher and we like love those
kinds of challenges so yeah so you
touched on this a little bit but
speaking of challenges I know when you
first launched the brand there was some
criticism about cultural appropriation
how did you navigate that and and how
would you address as critics today we
obviously learned we take notes and we
move forward I think that that we
addressed it at the time and we learned
from that experience and we we love the
consumer feedback and all those things
so we we really took that took the time
to recognize and and moved forward and
only wanted to better our brand from
that so awesome and Kendall I have two
more questions for you the first being
if you could go back in time and tell
your younger self something before
keeping it with Kardashians premiered
what would you say to the Kendall then
what advice would you have
um
I think advice would
be
like stop and smell the roses when you
can as cheesy as that sounds um but I
would also tell her that like enjoy the
ride it's going to be like a beautiful
one there's going to be ups there's
going to be downs but like everything's
going to be okay in the end and yeah
amazing good advice for anyone honestly
um and finally ending on a bit of a
lofty one what do you want your Legacy
to be oh my gosh um I mean obviously
that's a very deep question and I'm sure
people have given way better answers
that I'm about to give but I think
that again my corny my corny quotes
probably but like I think like I want to
uplift people I want people to I want
people to feel a positive feeling when
they hear my name see my face so I think
that that overall just happiness and
well-being is like all I would want from
anyone who has any love for me anywhere
and who remembers me down the line when
no one cares about me anymore I just
hope that like it's all positive and All
Good Vibes and I think that that yeah I
just want to yeah peace peace and love I
love it well thank you so much kend I
appreciate
[Music]
[Applause]
it